[Music]
in a hit and run news submitted by
agriculture a video catches a woman
going crazy after getting trapped while
trying to flee a hit open a door that
opens the other way okay you guys ready
this happened in Lake Elsinore
California yeah oh my god she doesn't
even see she's not very good at this
where she's going to Italy she got away
ranges [ __ ] crazy is her grandma for
her to be that scared oh you don't
understand my crime was gonna kill me
literally maybe we don't understand what
does she thinks gonna happen man she's
gonna get away scot-free down I know
she's on video he's got a license I like
the grandma's not gonna find out what
the [ __ ] front bumper inside the car
oh dear like when she first put the
bumper in and it's like in front of her
face I'm like how she gonna drive I
thought she had the [ __ ] the you know
the thing that blocks the Sun was on and
I'm like how'd she drive it with that
and cut to hurt an auto repair shop with
the guy looking at the bumper in front
of the car and he's like she's like yeah
I bump into something she's like I just
wanna go to volleyball practice yeah
oh why why you two for our way to a rave
or some [ __ ] damn dude that's [ __ ]
crazy I know so all I know is that her
name is Riley and suck no full name
I know her full name mmm-hmm what's her
Instagram Hey
oh she's cute yeah so right now the
Riverside County Sheriff's Department
damn Oh
Lake Elsinore would probably a teenager
yeah for sure her grandma's gonna get
her dude that's probably her grandma's
car with those type of cars and that
muffler I don't think so you know
there's bad my grandma's gonna kill me
you don't know how crazy my grandma is
Riverside behavior okay I feel like
whenever you think of Riverside you
think the trashiest like white people on
earth is that you really does that
Riverside yeah yeah and drugs I think
like yeah no matter what race you I
think it's like a [ __ ] ton of drugs
[ __ ] on a trash like everyone that
couldn't like live in LA they go out
there that's Orange County no rich
people in Orange County like Newport
Beach the ocean like washes the
methylene I dunno what you're talking
about like like the like Orange County
talk about trash you're like yeah but
Orange County's like cocaine rich drug
yeah but I don't think that because what
I think Orange County I think Newport
Beach and I think Huntington Beach and
[ __ ] like that and a neo-nazi gangs your
talk about like Santa Ana or something
yeah but what I think [ __ ] no I'm
talking about the Orange County kids I
knew growing up who were [ __ ] messy
talking about people which city's
[ __ ] have no [ __ ] idea hey hey
y'all hey you're from Orange County
right with municipality like nobody does
I'm talking about good no oh yeah yeah
when you're when I went to like middle
school and there was kids there who were
we're from Orange County and they moved
their middle school kids unmet no no no
they were messy bad messy families and
they moved into San Diego huh it was a
penalty dude I didn't know these be I'm
[ __ ] quiz their municipality bro kids
[ __ ] nobody does too much you guys
don't think that what do you think like
desert trash wet Riverside like yeah I
was never really in motocross kids yeah
like all of them just work at like gas
yeah I eat I people yeah
empire yeah like their favorite pastime
activities to go graffiti up an
abandoned neighbor
man these are really specific
stereotypes for like Riverside white
people I've never knew yeah I guess and
then they still Rock [ __ ] owes out there
do they that's what I picture you think
really in my head it's just fresh in my
head cuz I just came back from you're
just making stuff up think about it guys
dirtbike shooting fireworks out of a
Hannibal yeah it's yeah it's Trevor from
do you feel like this chick was driving
her boyfriend's car and her boy was
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of room baby
don't make it sad were laughing at her
grandma's car grandma her grandma like
Gemma from Senza anarchy I picture her
grandma she's popped Peg Bundy from sins
[ __ ] with like tattoos and like I guess
I speak for all the people watching this
video have no idea who that is uh katey
sagal no no no oh the character
character I don't know the character
Rosie Bundy so much TV Municipality you
want alright now I feel like I feel like
all the way people's there there they
all they're all a part of the biker
gangs I thought you guys were talking
about California and I'm from Washington
State well I mean this is a very
California conversation but a part of
California I've never experienced I
don't know what they're talking you know
have you guys ever had a hit and run
where you guys did the hit yo no never
I totally a car when I was 15 but I hit
a parked big rig what happened your
mother yeah no I just remembered a
sketch of when
I was 16 oh yeah tell me about this
sketch damn how long that take okay so
like a written skin thank God for phones
these days huh check it out like a
drawing next okay so this is the time
where I had just learned how to drive
and I got into a big fight at my mom's
house with my mom I ended up stealing
her car you wind your mom or no so I
took I took my stepdads car and I I left
for two days but during that time it was
around Halloween - my gosh anniversary
is coming up so such a [ __ ] girl
I smell so good Mike Hersey it goes to
the club meeting up with my boyfriend at
the time so then we end up at we so I
didn't know how to drive somehow I was
[ __ ] driving this whole night and my
friends convinced me to get on the
freeway and to get over my fear of
driving whatever I wind up getting very
wise by doing the most dangerous thing
on earth and so we do in high school
that was later on those I got three in
the morning so there was no cars but
then the drunk drivers 50 60 is not
scary anymore
that's I should always hit 150 first
please stop interrupting her hit-and-run
story we ended up going to this what zip
code were you in Jesus Christ I can tell
you that so then we go to this
restaurant I pull in to the parking lot
but then I ended up like eating whatever
I got a fight with my boyfriend I get it
back in the bag I just fought all night
yeah it was it was never so then exactly
so then when I'm pulling out so like if
these two are the cars that are parked
next to me and this is the car that I'm
in I pulled out so fast that I click
just hard from the corner of my car so I
just went like this and I was like oh
[ __ ] just left cuz I was the first of
all I was not like this we like pum pum
pum pum pum and then you'd leave that
was pretty bad no I hit it like twice
though oh [ __ ] okay yes it's a bump and
run but you took that away from me
it was a hit the sketch that I thought
of yeah the story that you were home
yeah no okay
we got I remember shooting breaks and
then I actually they never my parents
never looked at the car and notice that
I hit it it was that [ __ ] up the car
they could even tell you the new scratch
on it I don't think they even looked at
it
they were just pissed that I was gone
for two days yeah I I totaled the car
when I was fifteen how I was
it was stupid cuz me too I was texting I
was texting and driving first of all I
was gonna go meet some girl and then um
there was like the way the street is the
street naturally curves like it kind of
just it does this kind of like and then
then this the right side turns into like
like where people park you feel me um
there was a [ __ ] big rig parked there
and I was like literally like texting
and I looked up as I was heading
straight for that the road was curving I
didn't realize well they're all [ __ ] and
then it just like smoosh like the right
side of the car don't text it would you
have been smashed if you didn't swim I
would have a I would have died the
passenger if I had going I was going
fast enough to make that happen
yeah yeah but you know what's crazy you
know it's crazy so when I was like 10
years old a lady was massaging my mom
she was a psychic and a masseuse and she
told my mom told my mom that were not
with that when her Center when I'm 15 I
was gonna get into a big car accident
and then I remember no I don't know as I
remember being like German yes
well I squeal I want to know how they
what kind of it's magic this magic dude
I don't have the power I was just being
like 10 years old thinking that's
impossible when be famous how many into
a big accident and then you're a psychic
- I guess so
don't kill Tracy Morgan it wasn't until
I was 17 true well that's the thing it
wasn't till I was 17 I thought back when
I was like oh [ __ ] that psychic was
right but I got into a big accident I
just didn't you know I didn't get hurt
I'm always so interested in the after
that we always hear about people [ __ ]
total their cars [ __ ] what's the first
minute like you're like I gotta call I'm
on tour I completely [ __ ] up yeah I
called my dad I was like yeah [ __ ] first
accident ever choose like I you know and
then so my dad I was literally like a
few blocks from the house dude no Tim I
see you yeah but so then he came and
because it your car was it was we were
leasing the car it was like it was kind
of my car it was supposed to be like my
first kind of car car lease on did your
old man on the other Lola did your old
man unleash hell on you no he was like
he was nice about it it does he was
pretty tight
that's a nice you during this time yeah
but hold on I you were texting and
driving yeah yeah I mean they were
pissed but it was kind of like they're
just glad I was alive you know cuz the
car was like [ __ ] up yeah yeah
[Music]